hey
hello it's thursday night you can almost
taste the weekend
i mean the days not the singer cat
we got a great show ahead but first we
have to do this one
that was just uncalled for all right so
joe biden once again bringing back the
most despised coveted mandates in
america face diapering they're extending
the federal mass mandates on planes
trains and other public transit for
another 15 days add that to 14 days to
flatten a curve we're talking almost 30
days of inconvenience
so you have to wear them on your next
flight in between sips of water vodka
tequila or in my case the tears of
children
without it i'll shed this beautiful body
like a snake
and if you don't don the mask you'll
likely be scolded by someone with an axe
to grind now of course it depends on the
crew you got some are really great some
aren't like the attendant who wakes you
up from a harmless slumber because your
diapers slipped a millimeter like it's
an oxygen mask and they're saving your
life
meanwhile they didn't even notice i had
removed my boxers and filled them with
crushed ice and peach schnapps
yeah
of course this masked mandate is not
backed by science i can't find any
research saying today is any more covety
than 15 days from now if anybody could
show me that i'll send you some pictures
of tyrus that i took when he was
sleeping say what nothing
but does the virus need to give two
weeks notice before it quits
and besides research shows that planes
have the safest air around thanks to
hepa filters and efficient circulation
this is why they can keep serving
lentils for lunch
you didn't know that did you
anyway i read somewhere that if you
lived your whole life on a plane you'd
live longer with reduced risk for all
types of death true you're definitely at
less risk of getting shot unless your
plane flew over chicago
and yes i made up that stat but that's
what the experts do and even though this
mandate is pointless the media doesn't
think it goes far enough i mean why only
15 days
why only 15 days
well i think angie because it's a moving
target and we really want to see what
the pattern is here in the united states
he calls her age
here's the pattern fauchi hasn't noticed
covet is ending whether he likes it or
not he knows his 15 minutes are up so
he's trying to stay relevant 15 days at
a time and while everybody with a brain
hates masks the ladies of the view who
are exempt from the having a brain
category
they're on board
when it comes to things like flying yeah
the mandate is supposed to be lifted
april 18th i don't want to get on a
plane with super spreaders i don't want
to get on a plane with 214 other people
that are going to be breathing on me
with their coveted breath i don't want
it yeah i don't want it i want the mask
i want them to know where to where you
know then wear 20 masks and stay home
you creep
that's advice i'd give to the view even
if there wasn't a pandemic
no wonder a whoopi took off
the view is more dangerous than any
jumbo jet for one it's louder and spews
way more pollution
and if you think sunny's annoying on tv
imagine sitting next to her on a long
flight even al qaeda would say get me
off this plane
she's an a-hole she said she didn't want
people breathing on her with their
coveted breath people breathing on her
what is she slow dancing with people in
coach
do you think that's really about kovid
it's too hateful too angry and it
reveals their need for polarization
us versus them it's the thing among the
entitled in the elite when you run out
of race angles make it about disease
make it about the coven spreaders those
people with their covet breath they're
so gross i bet they're poor those
unwashed masses who fly coach and have
to bring their own snacks on board
usually beef jerky meanwhile the mask
wearers serve the hors d'oeuvres as
masculus big shots and first slobber
them down but it's all about blaming
others which gives hostin a good hit of
dopamine emphasis on dope and mean
of course our politicians exploit the
average person's instinct to be decent
they know we're not going to make a fuss
so you just hunker down and take the
punishment like a good sado masochist
ben over seat 18c waiting to be paddled
while double masked wearing both an n95
and a ball gag
what if they extend it again and then
they never stop at a certain point
flyers have to make a decision you keep
taking it or you share the risk and you
speak up they can't kick off four aisles
at once
well they probably can so i'm not
advocating it but at some point the
public must decide when the country's
had enough sort of like how democracy
was meant to work maybe the next two
weeks don't fly at all let them know
wait but greg i've got business in
albuquerque next week well guess what
now you've got an ear infection and you
can't fly pro orders of dr gutfeld yeah
i bet you didn't know i went to med
school that's cause i didn't but if it
doesn't stop dr jill
why should it stop me
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's dropped more gloves than o.j
simpson former nhl player and host of
the podcast no crux given sean avery
as a cab driver he used to drive people
and used cars now he dresses like he
sells them [ __ ] across america
post timmy fella
oh my god
she watched titanic and rooted for the
iceberg fox news contributor cat tim
and he's pinned more men than an
acupuncturist my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion tyrus
shawn welcome back to the show
where you been
i've been in california how's it going
over there there's a lot of democrats
yes
yes
yes a lot of dumps yeah yeah yeah sun
sun is out the sun is out but
yeah yeah yeah
was it tough
it's it is tough it is tough still
happening
i have to go back no don't go back stay
here i know we can i know you can bring
a cot you can sleep in the studio yeah
so what do you how do you feel about
this extra 15 days of mask wearing yeah
i mean it's uh it's uh so i catch covet
every time i fly really yeah um so i've
had it like probably 80 to 90 times in
the last two years yes
um i'm starting to build up immunity
yeah and uh it's going well i i love it
yeah that's great yeah so you're on team
view i i am uh well
yeah i don't know i don't know uh the
view is can we talk about that
yes yeah so i i really what i understand
now is sunny uh that's her name
sunny
sunny hates the middle class right
that's exactly what it is the middle
class that watches her show exactly
which i find ironic yeah yeah i'm not
sure if she knows that or
if anyone's ever pointed that out and
then the last thing i have on that where
did whoopi go i don't know this is the
mystery where is whoopee they said they
claim she's making a movie yes so i
bought that excuse yeah and oftentimes
i've been honest isn't it funny the
woman who won an oscar for ghost has
ghosted the view yeah he's like
she's done but you're right that whole
thing i saw was it was just uh a
reaction towards the huddled masses the
middle class it was like i can't be
around them i need separation much how i
feel about jimmy when you're wearing
the jacket and shoe combo stop it these
these shoes are dope by the way yeah
they are for dopes we can't all right
that was funny we can't all rob a
cabbage patch doll by the way where did
you find one that wears prada those are
nice
thank you it's an expensive cabbage
patch doll size nine minus four so
what's your feeling are you uh are you
going to fly
i mean i have flights booked like for
instance i'm headlining the tampa improv
thursday night may 5th um sorry are you
really yeah i am uh it's going to be a
banger but uh the whole the whole plane
thing is so dumb every ceo says we don't
need them yeah cdc says we don't need
them it's on the site the cdc site says
cloth masks don't work right anybody in
favor of wearing them just wear them you
know what i mean if you're on the plane
right you and your wife are gonna go
join the mile high club in the restroom
you don't ask the guy staying behind in
the road to put on a condom you know
what i mean you don't need it it's so
stupid that's an interesting analogy
it's there but i liked it but the fouchy
point
and no you're on to something with him
like he got addicted to being on tv
because understand he's been in this
position since 1984 yeah
geraldo
he has though he's had this job since
van halen recorded jump yes okay think
about that van halen has had three lead
singers we've had one fouchy yeah yeah i
would i would take sammy hagar at this
point or that guy from um extreme or
whatever the hell he was enough stuff
he was enough's enough that it was a
mess another mess but anyway you know
this he got addicted to going on tv he
can't get on tv if the pandemic goes
away so they just want to keep the mask
thing going and that's the only reason
there's no science it's all culture or
garbage you know what tyros you know
what would be a great solution for this
is if the airlines okay they have to
follow the rules but can couldn't they
just dial back their zero tolerance like
you know just like go hey i we're not
put on your mask and if it falls off
we're gonna leave you alone why can't
they do that it's
i don't want to out any of the good
people at delta but
i've
i've noticed less uh sticklerness yes um
but
i don't know greg you know i kind of
agree with that boycott flying thing
yeah
yeah he whiz
i'll just stay home until
this figures it out i mean are you
saying that that'll keep you from coming
to do the show yeah and i still get paid
because i'm you know
you're trying to game this you know what
i
but i would be remiss as a brother if i
did not talk about my good
sister friend sonny i know she thinks
the world revolves around her
but um
you're not wearing a mask on the view
surrounded by
people
and
you don't want to be on a plane
surrounded by people yeah hypocrite much
i mean
and you were yelling yes so you were
spewing your covenant
that's right on
everybody high risk good point and you
know what i love about the view is when
someone is drowning they never throw a
lifeboat nobody ever says oh yeah good
point move on it's true and that poor
guy with the cue card for applause held
that up aggressively
the crowd's like no no they finally
they're like fine we'll clap
but yeah she literally she was her own
super spreader right that's true of
idiocy and
vapors yeah that's true you know uh
cat there is always actions that in
which would obey are predicated on the
assumption that we're just gonna grin
and bear it i mean is this a hill to die
on when you're on a plane like would you
actually refuse would you do some kind
of refusal and end up no you're not no
i'm not gonna do that but i am gonna
[ __ ] about it yes
it is really sad yes people are sick of
it there's been a few times where i've
been picked up in an uber or a lift and
the driver's not wearing a mask
and i get so excited yeah i'm so excited
i can take my mask off and how sad is
that that i get to feel air on my face
and i'm like what a special treat
it's really depressing it's really
depressing especially because by the way
even with the masks people are still
breathing on you right you can like take
them off when you when you eat or you
drink uh and also i've noticed like when
i wear glasses and have my mask on they
get all fogged up yes so i think air is
going up there that's true that's true
it's it's a hygiene theater
there's already enough security theater
at the airport now we have hydrogen and
now we have hygiene theater and i'm sick
of all of us having to sacrifice things
so that people whose problem it isn't
can look like they're doing something
like joe biden's not flying commercial
no that's the point the dramatic rise in
airline prices coupled with getting
whacked in your face with a sports bra
politicians and rich celebrities don't
have to do
they can afford to fly private faa stats
there have been 704 mass related fist
fights this year okay so putting the
mask on is probably causing more health
damage because no one's getting covered
on a plane but 704 people have gotten
punched into the throat they've turned
commercial airlines into a flying waffle
house at three in the morning it's
insane oh i haven't been lucky enough to
been on any of those
that is something you would really enjoy
once one tipped off and i just told the
two little guys hey
i gotta get home
he would have had to do the suitcase
yeah the suitcase maneuver
i don't get to do that i still want you
to do do me this do the suitcase on me
no i gotta hit you first
i don't want that a limp body that makes
it easier to carry yeah
you don't want to do it on a squirming
yeah i promise i won't squirm all right
up next liberals are wigging out over
elon wielding too much clout that's
coming up after this momentary silence
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else